à
l'appel des déchets, il y en a
plusieurs comme ça ici en ville.
Les résidents qui sont venus
constater les dégâts, sortir les
premiers déchets. Des moments
très difficiles pour eux. Voici
ce qu'on vous a préparé.
- De la boue partout, des
maisons ravagées par les eaux.
C'est ce qui attendait
les sinistrés de Princeton
en entrant chez eux pour
la première fois depuis
les inondations.
- La résidence dn n n père
venait d'être vendue,
les locataires étaient sur
le point de partir.
Aujourd'hui, ils ne peuvent
qu'espérer que le bâtiment
n'aura pas à être démoli,
mais p p pourraient bien avoir
tout perdu.
- La maison se trouve tout près
du croisement de deux rivières.
Quand la digue a cédé, c'est
tout le quartier qui s'est
rapidement retrouvé englouti.
Sur la rue Fenchurch l'eau est
montée très haut.
Aujourd'hui, les résidents
dépités ne peuvent que constater
les dégâcocococommencer à jeter
tout ce qui a été détruit.
- Un cauchemar pour
ces résidents qui vivaient en
zone inondable, pas couv
par leurs assurances.
Mario Loutef a de l'aide pour
vider sa maison, mais sa femme
n'ose pas venir voir les dégâts
tellement elle est bouleversée.
- À Princeton toutes
les histoires se ressemblent.
Les sinistrés commencent à peine
à prendre la mesure de tout
ce qu'ils ont perdu.
- Ici le nettoyage et
les travaux de reconstruction
ne font que commencer.
- Le maire souligne que les gens
de Princeton devront être
paticlclclclclclame du même coup
l'aide du gouvernement.
- Le croisemx x x x x x rivières
est normalement ce qui fait
le charme de Princeton.
Si bien que même après ces
terribles inondations, certains
résidents ont bien l'intention
de v v v v v vivre tout près
de l'eau.
Avant de se lancer dans
un débat sur la reconstruction,
la ville, elle, promet de
rebatir une digue r r r r r rés.
ici Mathieu Gohier,
Radio-Canada, Princet